they say i get groupies at my shows oh
god damn lizzo is at it again here's the
teeth just weeks after joking that chris
evans is the father of her fake baby
we're gonna have a little america lizzo
posted a tick tock video showing off her
fake pregnant belly again they say i get
groupies at my shows oh god damn when a
fan shared a clip showing what chris and
lizzo's baby could hypothetically look
like fixing lizzo and chris evans to see
what their kids would look like the
singer was 100 percent here for it and
didn't waste any time showing off her
fake growing belly they say i get
groupies at my shows oh god damn the
grammy winner captioned the vid wait a
damn minute it's what we deserve lizzo's
captain america obsession kicked off
earlier this year when the singer
accidentally sent him a drunk dm the
reason i'm upset about this one is
because
i know i'm not going to be able to marry
him and honestly it hurts me to the
court because damn papa he a rare breed
no comparing he responded writing no
shame in a drunk dm god knows i've done
worse on this app lol i'm like damn this
is a big deal this is something that
i've been really trying to keep
personal and private just between me and
the father of my child but
since we're airing out all the rumors
today
i've been sucking in
[Music]
we're gonna have a little america and
although chris hasn't responded to
lizzo's latest video about
hypothetically what their kid might look
like he did respond to this one a few
days later lizzo shared what appears to
be a dm from the actor who seemingly
wrote quote hi just heard about her
little bundle of joy my mother will be
so happy lol it shook me up and it gets
even better because chris added this
hilarious request quote just promise me
no gender reveal parties lol i'm still
sweating girl okay i'm excited but the
33 year old singer is keeping her
options open
on tuesday lizzo was on jimmy kimmel
live with guest host niall horan and
let's just say things got flirty this is
the sexiest call i've ever been on yeah
me too
i'm getting a bit hot in this nutmeg
colored suit then things escalated real
quick when the two started talking about
their fan base names your fans go by
what the lesbians
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god it's amazing well i've sorted
out mine tonight mine are now called the
[ __ ] and dogs
oh
i like that yeah and it depends what
country you come from it sounds a little
bit different
oh in america it's a horn dog okay
we speak the same language i think
you're giving me a one erection baby
[Applause]
and move over chris evans because lizzo
joked that she's now trying to have a
baby with nile too you know because if i
was pregnant i would want to sit my ass
at home and prop my feet and eat some
hot cheetos and takis
i do that and i'm not even pregnant
and there you go you want to change that
[Applause]
[Music]